I want to pull up the story we have this
from The Daily Mail this is this is
theast this is the headline they're
running US Embassy in Lebanon is set on
fire as thousands of pro Palestinian
riers waving Hezbollah banners and
circle the compound before security DSes
them in tear gas Rider plants flag in
fence as day of unprecedented anger gets
underway so this is the the official
reporting US Embassy under attack I I
certainly hope they they that they get
our people out of here I mean I don't I
don't know what Biden thinks he's going
to Lish going into the region right now
at this degree of escalation but I
certainly hope that our our presence
there gets our people out of these
embassies and maybe it's time we just
say see you later well and to Libby's
point though in terms of the
intelligence I mean look at the open
source intelligence here uh we have a
potentially escalating conflict the
United States president is coming to
visit and we just moved two uh strike
carrier groups into the region perhaps
we should have thought maybe uh there
could be an issue with our Embassy in
Lebanon which is essentially controlled
by Hezbollah
right like it seems like there's been a
just a ton of intelligent failures for
the past few weeks yeah every or maybe
they're not failures or maybe I I I I
agree with Max Blumenthal he said this
was an intelligence failure on the part
of Israel this Max is is is very pro pro
Palestine and his view is that Israel
would never be humiliated in this way
they wouldn't allow it they wouldn't
allow one of their soldiers to be taken
because it puts them in such a weak
position so I see these arguments I saw
a clip from Charlie Kirk that there's an
argument that it benefits Israel to a
great degree to have allowed this to
happen but I think the detriment to
Israel for this happening the obvious
detriment for the civilians dying but
even politically is is it doesn't make
sense that they were yeah I I I don't
agree with that I think what part of the
things and we've talked about this
before
is how cheap and sophisticated
technology is now so Hezbollah and Hamas
in particular they have drones they have
the ability to see where people are
moving you can buy infrared cameras you
can I mean so they've been tracking and
there was an article out there about
they knew exactly where one of these
Israeli intelligence centers was just
right over the Border they were supposed
to be monitoring this kind of activity
and took them out immediately and they
knew when those guys were coming when
they were going because they've been
using drones and things of that nature
to be able to to track that type of
thing and that's where you know you
you're always talking about this
qualitative military Edge qualitative
qualitative it's some point
quantitative does become qualitative and
where you're able to have a lot of
assets and this is where the Iranians
swarm technology uh or swarm tactics
rather around US Naval vessels and
things like that are so dangerous sure
yeah look we got an aircraft carry what
are you going to do if you got 20,000
boats coming at it are you going to
shoot them allly it's like piranhas
little and ya they kill you you start to
think too about um how the Americans won
in the revolution I know we had like
French support and all of that stuff but
we also kind of invented Grill of
warfare a little bit you know yes that's
a big deal yes so if you have and and
the difference too is that American
soldiers are not ideologically driven
here um but we're fighting an
ideological enemy that believes fully
that the best thing that they can do is
die as as martyrs to their cause they
teach their children that I mean there
were um there were TV shows like I
forget what it was called I know I have
it on here somewhere in one of these
5,000 tabs I have opened but um but
there were TV shows that were running in
like 2007 to
2014 in Gaza and the West Bank that were
produced in the West Bank at TV studios
and it was uh like cartoon like a like a
like a sort of Mickey Mouse type of
character yeah and it was teaching them
that being jihadis was their best option
for life it uh you know the the
extremism of this islamist ideology and
the way that it really changed I think
when the terrorists started uh pushing
it fully wellis it's really yeah I mean
it's really destructive obviously it's
really destructive but um how do you
fight someone that wants to die exactly
right well in you know that ideology you
mentioned to bring that full circle back
to what we're talking about just a
moment
ago there's people on colleges campuses
chanting from The River To The Sea
that's so terrifying from The River To
The Sea what does that mean that means
the annihilation of the Jewish state of
Israel that means the
annihilation of the Jews in that land
yeah that's what that means from The
River To The Sea yes it does and so that
that that's why you ask any leftist
they're not going to give you a straight
answer what would happen if the security
fencing around Gaza was removed and
Israel said everyone here you can just
go do whatever you want even the left
knows the right will say it explicitly
oh yeah they'll go and start killing
citizens and civilians right they'll
call them settlers the the left will
just hem and haw and deflect because
they know what the answer is you know I
and I think the reason why you get this
answer um from leftist which is they'll
try and Dodge it they can't publicly say
oh we know what will happen and then
gloat in their calling for what would
eventually be civilian deaths they also
know that they publicly state that Hamas
should not do it the leftists are going
attack them saying you think they should
bow down to settlers blah blah blah the
left really has they they know most
people oppose what they're proposing and
they know the left would take issue if
they reject what the left is proposing
right so they have they can't answer the
question
honestly yeah it's terrifying thinking
about the gorilla the gorilla Warfare
stuff too is like it made me think of
Vietnam sure and it was so bad with the
gorilla Warfare over there that we had
to seed the clouds to try to start water
like rain to fall to to destroy their
their Pathways to fight them you know
fighting that kind of stuff is
impossible the the the craziest thing
that I the scops of Vietnam my my one of
my favorite military Concepts when they
would play they put speakers in the
jungle playing the sound of a wailing
Vietnamese Soldier saying why did I
fight why didn't I go home to be my
family I'm trapped forever while you can
don't be trapped like me because the
Superstition the Vietnamese was that if
you weren't given a proper burial you
were doomed to WAND the Earth so they
would play these spooky ghost sounds
that were so effective the South
Vietnamese would flee as well so they
had to stop doing it but in that regard
that's old school that's you know 50
some odd years ago the psychological
operations we're going to see now are
going to be all social media based right
and they've been happening for some time
yep so I mean look these videos we're
watching we are we are at the point it
could be now that these videos are AI
generated yes and we are like wow look
at this atrocity in the photos and
everything we had the argument over
whether the photo was air generated
already this is this is a horror show
yeah I mean the United States can put
out videos of anything they want using
AI yep and what are you going to do
every journalist just agrees with it and
then there's no journalism anymore yeah
how are you well we're in that you know
that is a that is a tough spot it's like
that evil and W novel scoop where
journalists just show up to the war zone
and the one guy shows up to the war zone
and he's like where's the war and
everyone's like shh there isn't really
one wow just well I remember this was a
big uh there was a big social media
troll campaign several years ago where
people were taking old photos of like
military convoys and then tweeting that
I can't believe this is happening and
they were saying something in like Ohio
I can't remember which state it was and
then I'm on Twitter and I'm seeing all
these posts where they're like dude it's
happening now everyone was in on it it
was a game but a lot of people didn't
understand and thought it was real you
see you see a video of like a tank
driving down the street then you see
like police pushing people back and
everyone was climbing the all these
things were one incident that happened
when it was just random videos stuff put
together maximum maximum absurdity with
unbridled horror on the internet and uh
that is what is driving me insane being
on Twitter every time I open it up CU I
see you know something has been
confirmed then that immediately that
that thing has been canceled out uh yeah
it's crazy and I still don't want to
suppress that the bad information I I
think it just needs to be out there so
we can can fight it cuz I see other
people calling for it to be somehow
suppressed or have Twitter step in which
I also think is ridiculous well dude I
guarantee like the operation T was
talking about was called operation
wandering soul and I guarantee if
anyone's look into it I don't know if
the chat is is interested but if if you
don't think that there's something like
that going on or at least numerous
operations that are going on right now
to both combat uh this new AI uh I guess
we'll call misinformation and to create
new information as well because you know
the best defense is a good offense then
you're kidding yourself there are
definitely things going on right now
that you don't know about and none of us
know about and we can't speak anything
about and neither neither could you I'm
sure as well we don't know and just the
knowledge of the AI stuff happening
makes it so people are there's so
there's
wi buil in yeah yeah exactly it's
already part of the operation just to
know that this is going on it's already
one of the things they're aware of right
in one of these operations that's going
on yeah it's vide so many of the videos
are like so incredibly emotional you
know because if you are first struck
with an emotion and you're going to
react in a you know in a way that that
corresponds to that and you're not going
to question it first when they get you
with your feelings first that's when you
really have to watch out and be careful
that's something we talk about at post
millennial all the time with the social
media team and we're all like okay you
just got to chill you got to stay frosty
you got to like keep your about yeah
that's something actually Jack bobic
said a while ago he was like Stay Frosty
and we're like
nice that's good I know where you're
getting that my friend thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net